Können wir anfangen?
Hallo, guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Ich bin die Sabin, der erst auf dieser Station,
Joseph ist mein Name,
und würde gerne mit Ihnen dieser Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Nehmen Sie Platz, bitte.
Ja, danke schön.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Anna Keller.
Anna Keller, Doppel-N und Doppel-L.
Anna Keller.
Frau Keller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 68 Jahre alt.
68 und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 9., 17.54.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Keller?
Ich bin 1,68 m.
68.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
99.
79 kg.
Sehr gut.
Frau Keller, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was führt Sie zu uns heute?
Ich habe solche Schmerzen hier oben im Bauch.
Das hat vor einigen Tagen,
eigentlich ist das schon eine ganze Weile,
dass ich immer mal Schmerzen habe.
Ich dachte, ein bisschen Magen-Schmerzen.
Aber jetzt ist es schlimmer geworden.
Seit zwei Tagen ist es wirklich ganz schlimm.
Ich muss mich schon übergeben, 2-mal.
Einmal, ne?
Bitte?
Einmal, muss man Sie übergeben.
2-mal schon.
2-mal.
Ja, ja, ja.
Da ist mir auch gefallen.
Dass das irgendwie so ein bisschen ausser,
als ob da Blut drin wäre.
Da bin ich dann doch ein bisschen erschrocken.
Dann habe ich gedacht,
ich muss wohl doch mal in das Krankenhaus gehen.
Sie haben sehr gut entschieden.
Sie haben gesagt,
seit 2 Tagen
ihre Schmerzen schlimmer geworden.
Aber seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ein bisschen ist es eigentlich schon seit 2 Wochen.
Dann habe ich gedacht, ich habe vielleicht ein bisschen was verkehrtes gegessen.
Aber nein, es wurde gar nicht besser.
Und jetzt ist es eben seit 2 Tagen richtig deutlich Schmerzen.
Alles klar.
Wie können Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Was für ein Schmerz ist das?
Stechend, zehend?
Stechend vielleicht.
Es ist eigentlich so ein ganz dumm Verdruck,
als ob man da Ziegelsteine im Bauch hat.
Dumm Verschmerz.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen im Oberbauch?
Oberhalb vom Bauchnabel.
Nicht auf dem Maagengrober.
Bitte?
Nicht auf Magengrober,
sondern die Schmerzen.
Ein bisschen höher.
Also oberhalb vom Nabel würde ich sagen.
Nicht unten im Bauch, wo man so Darmbeschwerden hat.
Wenn man Blähungen hat oder Durchfall.
So nicht, sondern eben weiter oben.
Alles klar.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Zum Beispiel, wenn Sie messen würden auf eine Schmerzskala
von 1 bis 10, 1 für 1,
leichtestens und 10 für am stärksten Schmerz.
Wo können Sie die Schmerzen einschätzen?
Die sind schon echt tüchtig, die Schmerzen.
Ich denke so, jetzt,
weil ich dann endlich gekommen bin, sind die bei 7.
7.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen bisher nicht
unser Gesprächs aushalten oder brauchen Sie die Schmerzen?
Das ist ja auch ein bisschen schwer.
Ich kann das schon, ich habe das ja jetzt schon ein paar Tage.
Und das Komische ist,
wenn ich nachdem ich mich übergeben habe,
da werden die Schmerzen eigentlich ein bisschen besser.
Besser, mit Erbrechen.
Ja, nachdem erbrechen geht es ein bisschen besser.
Aber deswegen kann ich jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit mich übergeben.
Ich habe das ja schon ein paar Tage.
Das komische ist, nachdem ich mich übergeben habe,
dann kann ich jetzt ja nicht die ganze Zeit mich übergeben.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt,
dass die Schmerzen verursacht,
oder gibt es etwas,
die Schmerzen lindert oder verschlechtert,
außerhalb Erbrechen Sie haben?
Also ich würde sagen, wenn ich versuche, was zu essen,
ich habe natürlich Hunger
und will eigentlich irgendwas essen.
Aber wenn ich dann etwas esse,
dann fängt es wieder an zu drücken.
Aber wenn Sie erbrechen,
dann geht es besser.
Ja, nachdem geht es dann für eine Weile wieder ein bisschen besser.
Wann war Ihre letzte Erbrechen?
Mein letztes Erbrechen.
Ja.
Oder was haben Sie gefragt?
Ja, genau.
Heute Morgen.
Und wie sieht die Erbrechen aus?
Das Erbrochene.
Wie das so aussieht.
Also das kleingekaute Zeug,
das man gegessen hat.
Dann dachte ich, das sieht so ein bisschen blutig aus.
Ja, blutig und essenrester.
Hatten Sie früher solche Bechwerden
oder ist das erstmal aufgetreten?
Nee, das ist das erste Mal.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen immer da
oder Sie kommen und wieder weg?
Nee, also nicht so wellen.
Sie werden nur beim Essen prühen.
Dann wird es mir dann einmal schlimmer
und ja.
Aber da waren da.
Sie sind eigentlich dauernd da.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie
Herzrasen
oder Herzklopfen gehabt?
Ja, eigentlich nicht mehr,
als sonst würde ich sagen.
Aber haben Sie Fieber,
Schüttelfrost, Nachtschweiß,
solche Dinge?
Ja, also das Einzige, was mir so aufgefallen ist,
ich muss zur Zeit immer so ein bisschen husten,
aber da kommt gar nichts.
Das ist so ein trockener Husten.
Und mir ist halt schlecht.
Ich habe zwar Hunger
und denke, ich muss etwas essen,
aber eigentlich habe ich nicht Appetit.
Mir ist ein bisschen schlecht.
Und ich fühle mich total schlapp.
Aber rein ist lieber, ne?
Lieber, also ich habe nicht gemessen,
aber das ist mir jetzt eigentlich nicht aufgefallen.
Aber in der Nacht haben Sie eigentlich recht.
Also nachts habe ich jetzt die Tage schon ein bisschen geschwitzt.
Ja, das habe ich aber irgendwie gar nicht so.
Ich dachte, das liegt an der neuen Winterdecke oder so.
Hab ich gar nicht so gemerkt, aber ich schwitze nachts zur Zeit.
Aber Ihre Appetit ist sozusagen gut, ne?
Nein, gar nicht.
Also ich habe Hunger, ich habe das Gefühl,
ich müsste etwas essen, weil der mag mehr Essen,
aber ich habe überhaupt gar keinen Appetit.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Ich ist da nichts auffällig.
Haben Sie Luftnot gehabt?
Nee, Luftnot, nee.
Also ich muss zwar husten, aber dass ich jetzt das Gefühl habe,
ich kriege keine Luft, ne, das habe ich nicht.
Oder Brustschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen,
Schwinkelschmerzen,
Brustschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen,
Schwinkelschmerzen.
Nee, das eigentlich nicht.
Nee, mehr so nur eigentlich diese Bauchschmerzen, diese Heftigen.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie Schluckbeschwerden oder Sortbrennen?
Nee, das habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Dann gut.
Frau Keller, jetzt möchte ich noch ein paar Fragen stellen,
um ein umfassendes Bild Ihrer Krankengeschichte zu haben.
Gibt es in Ihrem Vorgeschicht wichtige Krankheiten,
von denen ich wissen sollte,
oder leider sind sie unter einer chronischen Krankheit?
Ja, also ich habe tatsächlich seit 10 Jahren
eine rheumatische Erkrankung, Arthritis,
und da muss ich auch manchmal
Medikamente einnehmen.
Da kriege ich so, wie heißt denn das?
Da kriege ich so Medikamente gegen die Entzündung.
Ja, wissen Sie den Namen?
Ich habe so ein Zettel, was ich alles nehme.
Dann habe ich noch Bluthochdruck.
Bluthochdruck habe ich noch.
Und da kriege ich seitdem ich die Erkrankungen habe,
da kriege ich seit 10 Jahren auf Tabletten.
Und was ich nehme, das ist Kapto-Pril.
Wie bitte?
Ich nehme Kapto-Pril, ich weiß aber nicht, wofür das ist.
Und dann nehme ich...
Das ist Kapto-Pril 25, und dann nehme ich morgens und abends ein.
Alles klar.
Auch die beiden, sie sind seit 10 Jahren.
Das andere Medikament, das heißt, präten die Solonen.
Ich glaube, das ist gegen diese Rheuma Entzündung.
Ja, genau.
Und die Dosis auch ehrenerlich?
Das sind auch 15 Milligramm, dann nehme ich morgens eine.
15?
Ja.
Und dann nehme ich noch die Kluffe nackt gegen die Rheuma Schmerzen.
50 Milligramm, dann nehme ich 3 Mal am Tag.
Also es sei denn, es geht mir super gut, dass ich gar keine Schmerzen habe.
Wegen Akustik, ich konnte nicht gut hören.
Wie viele Milligramm, haben Sie gesagt?
50.
Sehr gut.
Und sind Sie schon mal operiert worden, Frau Keller?
Das muss ich überlegen.
Nein, eigentlich habe ich noch keine Operation gehabt in meinem langen Leben.
Nein, ist noch nix.
Oder waren Sie schon mal im Krankenhaus?
Haben Sie einen Unfall gehabt?
Nein, nein, nein.
Das freut mich.
Sind bei Ihnen eine Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Nein, also allergisch, soweit ich weiß, bin ich auch gar nichts.
Sie sehen kerngesund aus.
Ja, wobei mein Mann sagt, ich bin ein bisschen blass.
Ja, er sagt, ich bin ein bisschen blass, sie kennen mich ja nicht so gut.
Rauchen Sie, Frau Keller?
Ja, seit 20 Jahren rauche ich.
Und ja, so ein Päckchen am Tag ungefähr.
Päckchen am Tag.
Das ist ein bisschen aber mehr.
Und trinken Sie auch Alkohol?
Ja, also ein paar Mal in der Woche gönne ich mir abends im Glas Wein.
Zum Essen je nachdem, oder wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt.
Jeden Abend, oder?
Ja, so.
Wir sind dann so drei, vier Mal in der Woche abends trinken wir ein Glas Wein.
Pro Woche?
Ja.
Nehmen Sie bitte das nicht persönlich, das ist eine routine Frage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Nein, mit Drogen habe ich nie irgendwas zu tun gehabt.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Kinderkrankheiten und auch Covid-19?
Ja, so viel ich weiß, habe ich alle notwendigen Impfungen immer bekommen.
Also auch Grippeimpfungen und so etwas.
Und gegen Covid bin ich auch dreimal geimpft.
Sehr gut.
Frau Okela, wir sind fast fertig, aber ich möchte noch ein paar Fragen über Ihre Familie und Ihre Sozial-Leben stellen.
Alles verstandlich?
Ja, klar.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Meine Mutter lebt noch, mein Vater ist an einem Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Und meine Mutter ist erstaunlich gesund, obwohl sie ja nun auch schon ganz schön alt ist.
Obwohl?
Weil sie ziemlich alt ist.
Aber sie ist gesund.
Wann ist Ihre Vater gestorben?
Sie meinen, wie alt er war?
Ja.
Da waren wir 82.
Alles klar, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe eine Bruder und ein Schwestern.
Und die sind auch gesund?
Ja, die sind beide auch gesund.
Ja, Mutter ist Gehende.
Ja, das freut mich auch.
Wie Sie.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja wohl.
Ja.
Und leben Sie auch mit wem?
Noch mal rein.
Mit wem leben Sie zurzeit?
Mit meinem Mann.
Ja, die sind schon groß, die sind aus dem Haus.
Sind Sie rausgeflogen?
Die Vögel sind ausgeflogen.
Ja, die sind schon erwachsen.
Was machen Sie beruhig?
Ich war mal lebenglange Hausfrau.
Der Haken ist ich, ich bin jetzt nicht in Rente, ich bin immer noch Hausfrau.
Ich bin immer noch Hausfrau.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine lange Reise gemacht?
Oder waren Sie im Ausland?
Nein, wir waren immer nur hier.
Frau Keller, ich prüfe, ob ich alle wichtige Informationen habe.
Jetzt haben wir unser Gespräch beendet.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, natürlich.
Was kann man jetzt untersuchen?
Woher kommt das, dass es mir so schlecht geht?
Und dass ich Schmerzen habe?
Ja, ich werde alles Sie erklären.
Noch eine Frage.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, leider nicht abgenommen.
Ich wünschte mir manchmal, mit 79 kg bin ich ja gut dabei.
Aber ich habe nicht abgenommen.
Ja, das ist stabil.
Gut.
Hatten Sie keine Probleme mit Ausscheidung?
Leiden Sie nicht an die Jahre Durchfall oder Verstopfung?
Durchfall oder Verstopfung habe ich nicht.
Aber was mir auch nicht?
Ich habe nicht die Frage, ob ich in der letzten Zeit
eine kleine Reise gemacht habe.
Verstopfung habe ich nicht.
Aber was mir aufgefallen ist,
dass in der letzten Zeit der Stuhl ging,
dass der so auffällig dunkel war.
Dunkel.
Wie per Stuhl sieht?
Vielleicht nicht ganz so dunkel, aber schon dunkler ist normal.
Seit wann haben Sie das gemerkt?
Das habe ich jetzt ein paar Tage gemerkt,
seit es mir nicht so schlecht geht.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie einige Schmerz,
Mietzels einnehmen.
Aber haben Sie auch einen Magenschutz dabei?
Magenschutz nehme ich nicht.
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Frau Keller,
ich habe einen Verdacht
auf bei Ihren Bauchspeicheldrösen Entzündung.
Aber das bleibt natürlich nur ein Verdacht,
bis weitere Untersuchungen abgeschlossen sind.
Jetzt werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen
und in der nächsten Zeit
eine Bauchultrischal verordnen.
Dann sehen wir weiter.
Das klingt ja, das klingt nach einem guten Plan.
Wie lange dauert das alles?
Vielleicht müssen Sie bei uns bleiben.
Für heute.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Wir müssen uns bleiben.
Damit wir gucken, ob alles mit dem Körper in Ordnung ist.
Das kann ich verstehen.
Wir sehen uns gleich.
Wunderbar.
Bis später.
Ein paar haben jetzt auf schriftlichen Wege rein.
Ich möchte sonst noch irgendjemandes wissen.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, die Kinder sind gesund.
Schwindelig ist mir auch nicht.
Sie sagen gescheit,
wenn sie so weit sind,
dass sie Arzt-Arzt-Geschwicht machen können.
Sie sagen, dass sie Arzt-Arzt-Geschwicht machen können.
Ja, genau.
Das werde ich gleich Bescheid sagen.
Können wir starten?
Ja, können wir.
Hallo Frau Oberärztin.
Ich möchte Hallo sagen.
Mit einer Frau,
mit einer Frau,
mit einer Frau, mit einer Frau, mit einer Frau.
Ich möchte Hallo sagen.
Mit einer Patientin.
Ich bin neuer Kollege hier.
Frau Keller, 68-Jährige.
Patientin.
Heute kam zu uns mit
Oberbauchschmerzen.
Die Schmerzen sind seit
zwei Wochen bestehen.
Seit zwei Tagen sind sie schlimmer geworden.
Des Weiteren
beschreibt die Patienten die Schmerzen
dumpf und
residivierend.
Die Schmerzintensität
liegt
in der Schmerz-Geschwicht.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt
bei sieben von zehn
auf eine Schmerzskala.
Und die Schmerzen
würden sich
beim Essen
verschlechtern
und beim Erbrechen
vermindern.
Außerdem
fühlt sich die Patienten
ein bisschen schlapp.
Diese Beschwerden sind erstmal
aufgetreten.
Und außerdem
berichtet die Patienten
eine unproduktive
Kosten
und
die Schmerzintensität
in der Schmerz-Geschwicht.
Die gezielte Frage
nach Tarekade,
Palpitation,
Fieber,
Disfagi
und Reflu
und
die Schmerzintensität
in der Schmerz-Geschwicht.
Die Patienten
sind schon seit zehn Jahren
verantwortlich.
Die Schmerzintensität
liegt in der Schmerz-Geschwicht.
Das ist die Schmerz-Geschwicht.
Roma Deut, Atretis und Atelierli Pertonier.
Dagegen nimmt sie Pretenisolon, 15 Milligramm, einmal morgens,
Kaptobril 25 Milligramm, morgens und abends und Dickler-Fenner 50 Milligramm, 3 Mal.
Sie nehmen keinen Magenschutz dazu und sind bei ihr keine Allergien- oder
Unverträglichkeiten bekannt. Sie raucht seit 20 Jahren ein Packung
im täglichen, beziehungsweise 20 Packungen. Sie trinken Alkohol, ein Glas Wein,
3-4 Mal pro Woche, Drogenkonsum wurden verneint. Sie ist 3 Mal geimpft gegen Covid-19,
Infektion und vollständig geimpft gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Kreep.
Im Punkt in der Familienanamnese zeigt sich, ihr Vater ist ein Herzinfarkt,
im Alter von 82 gestorben. Ihr Mutter ist gesund.
Sie hat 2 Geschwister, die auch gesund sind. Sie ist verheiratet und lebt mit
ihrem Mann zusammen. Hausfrau von Beruf und Reise an Amnese ist unaufwählig.
Auf den Anamnästchen an der Abend gehe ich von Verdacht auf Akute Pancreatitis.
Aber die finanzielle Diagnostik kommt,
Ulcus ventriculi, sowie oesophagitis auch in Betracht.
Ich würde diese Maßnahmen empfehlen.
Ich würde die Patienten ausführlich und körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie dabei?
Ich würde eine Fluctuation.
Im Labor testen würde ich Blutbildentzündungsparameter,
Herzensimen um ein Herzinfarkt auszuschließen.
Ich würde ein EKG durchführen.
Was erwarten Sie im Blutbild?
Wenn die Patient an Anämie leidet, dann sehen wir Hemoglobinabfall.
Was schauen Sie in der Sonografie?
Ich würde eine Sonografie durchführen.
Ob es eine Verdickung der Entzündungszeichen im Bereich Oberwahrung,
im Epikastricht Raum, im verdickten Ankeriaskleid.
Wenn die Patient versteckte Blutung, dann könnte er ein Gastroskopi erforderlich sein.
Was würde man bei der Gastroskopie noch mitmachen?
Was meinen Sie?
Man würde nicht nur gucken.
Mit Bioxy.
Ich würde eine Erzipoldiagnostik, also therapeutisch,
eine Erzipoldiagnostik, also therapeutisch, ein Erzipoldiagnostik,
eine Verstopfung oder Verengung geben können wir, die Gänge erweitern.
Was spricht Ihrer Meinung nach für die Pankreatitis?
Die Oberbauchschmerzen und die Beschwerden würden sich nach Erbrechen hindern.
Was ist denn typisch für die Schmerzen?
Normalerweise erwarten wir von dieser Patient ein Gürtelförmige Oberbauchschmerzen.
Ich werde das auch in einem körperlich untersuchen bestätigen.
Gut, wenn es sich bestätigt, dass es eine Pankreatitis ist,
dann machen Sie diese Geilengangdarstellung.
Was würde man auf alle Fälle noch machen?
Was therapeutisch, wenn mein Verdacht sich bestätigt,
würde ich der Patientennahrungskarenz empfehlen
und sofort eine Infusiontherapie anfangen,
und Analgetik umzugeben.
Die hat ja auch nicht gespürt.
Und noch ein RCP würde ich erfolgen.
Gut, tatsächlich war es nicht die Pankreatitis,
sondern es war eine gastrointerstinale Blutung.
Das war mein Vettardiagnose.
Es war die Blutung, wo das Blutige erbrechen und der dunkle Stuhl spricht.
Das wäre bei der Pankreatitis nicht unbedingt zu erwarten.
Dann war hier als Nachtrag, wenn tatsächlich ein Blutendes Urnkurs besteht,
was würde man dann auf alle Fälle noch im Magen testen?
Immer auf Kult testen, meinen Sie oder?
Nein, was ist denn gerne ein Auslöser von Magenproblemen?
Diese NSA auch Medikamente.
Das wäre natürlich die eine Geschichte.
Das ist in Ihrem Fall durchaus gut möglich.
Herr Reger, am meisten Helicobacterpillori.
Wenn das positiv ist, dann müssen wir ein Erradikationstherapie verschreiben.
Für diese Patienten gibt es zwei übliche Schämer dafür.
Sehr gut, ja.
Italienisch oder französisch?
Ich merke schon, ich renne offene Türen ein, Sie wissen alles.
Gut, das war noch eine Nachfrage, die hier die Brüfer gestellt haben.
Deswegen habe ich das noch mal nachgefragt.
Super, wunderbar.
Sie haben eine sehr schöne Anamnese gemacht.
Auch eine vollständige Wiedergabe und Bericht.
Ich denke schon, dass das auch sprachlich.
Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, absolut brillant.
Aber doch im sehr weit oberen Bereich.
Alles gut verständlich.
Eigentlich ohne irgendwelche sprachlichen Probleme.
Auch in dem Arztgespräch konnten Sie jede Frage beantworten.
Ich habe schon mal ein paar Fragen und konnten immer sagen,
was die Patientin gesagt hat.
Zahlen stimmten auch alle, das ist oft auch so eine Schwierigkeit.
Das war eine sehr schöne Vorstellung, würde ich sagen.
Wann dürfen Sie zur Prüfung?
Nächste Woche.
Das läuft, ja, das läuft.
Können Sie sehr entspannt hingehen.
Wann ist Ihr Prüfungstag?
Im Hannover.
Wann?
Nächste Freitag.
Dann werden wir mal kollektiv die Daumen drücken für Sie.
Für heute würden wir uns dann verabschieden.
Ich hatte das angekündigt.
Ich bin jetzt dann paar Tage im Urlaub.
Ich glaube bis elf, oder?
Genau.
Dann haben Sie Ihr Elend schon hinter sich.
Ich freue mich immer zu hören, was rausgekommen ist.
Denn Sie, wie Dr. Gündes mir Nachricht geben, freue ich mich.
Natürlich, ich gerne ein Bescheid.
Für alle anderen wünsche ich eine gute Zeit.
Für Sie natürlich auch.
Für Sie aber ganz besonders ein gutes Gelingen bei der Prüfung.
Wir werden alle zusammen Daumen halten.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit und Ihre Mühe.
Ja, gerne. Viel Erfolg.
Für heute schönen Abend.
Und schönen Abend noch.
Danke.